hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become welcome back to another
workout I'm Jenna so and today's workout
is a beginner low impact cardio workout
so if you haven't been active or perhaps
you used to be active but you have
stopped for a really long time and you
want to start moving again this workout
is for you it's a low-impact workout and
I'll be guiding you through each workout
okay so it's going to be really gentle
on your knees so let's start by marching
on the spot so I want you to just start
by much on the spot to get your body
warm up remember I want you to take it
at your own pace so if you feel that you
can't bring your knees higher then go
ahead and bring your knees higher if not
you can start by just doing small steps
okay just breathe in and breathe out the
reason for us to do our warm-up is to
get the blood in our body flowing and to
get our muscles ready good keep marching
at the spot swing your arms side to side
and now I want you to get into lake
curls so just step side to side and curl
and bring your heels to your butt again
opening and closing your arms and you
should feel the stretch on your chest
very good there you go so step side to
side keep your knees bent and keep your
knees soft keep going
stretch open up feel the stretch on your
chest and feel your upper body warming
up as well nice now let's continue to
March and what a way to do is reach side
to side okay so reach the opposite side
and we want to stretch a little bit on
our back as well as our shoulders good
so reach up grab it imagine you're
grabbing something
right at the top reach for the stars
good and tiptoe ponytails
twist the hips we want to warm up those
hips as well this is going to be a total
body cardio workout good
now slowly reach side twist twist even
more very good keep twisting and move
your shoulders and just March it up good
and now still on our warm up I want you
to get into few squats so just lower
your butt down and reach up okay
so lower your butt down reach up look up
open up your chest come back down and
squeeze your gluts again up reach up and
squeeze a bit very good up open up your
chest straight back and up nice you
should feel the stretch along your lats
your arms as well as working on your
legs and your glutes keep going one more
last one and just March it out
continue too much all right so the first
workout is going to be a high knee pull
what I want to do is then shoot it with
a part with the toes pointed forward I
want to reach up bring one knee up and
pull it down okay so I want you to
crunch in and pull it back down
so this workout will work on your core
at the same time you will be working on
the legs as well as your arms okay the
goal is to bring your knee as high as
you can so again reach up pull it crunch
your abs and crunch it ready let's go up
reach and reach good there you go so by
keeping yourself balanced
you will also view your Co working keep
going up and reach only 40 seconds for
each workout and you will get a 20
seconds rest if you feel that you are
struggling well you can always just tap
and tap ok if not reach and drive your
knee in towards your chest keep going
ten more seconds good and remember to
always
pace your breathing so breathe in and
breathe out and rest it out very good
the next workout is going to be a squat
with front kick so just like I'm a
warm-up I were to squat it down to reach
down as you come up give me a nice front
kick okay
and squat back down come back up and
give me the last kick good so with the
kicks I want you to mean it
let's go squat down up and kick squat
down up and kick good down and kick
forward and always keeping your arms up
nice squat down kick down and kick
remember to control the kicks good kick
with your heels nice kick it forward and
look straight ahead so remember with
your squats you should be pointing your
toes and your knees forward keep going
go as low as you can with your squats if
this is too tough you can always just do
a half squat and kick very good now
breathe in and breathe out
next let's work on our upper body jab
cross
so again arms into a fist close your
face I want you to just give me a jab
and a cross and remember to always twist
your hips and point your toes okay
let's go left right left right
good and relax your shoulders just a
slight bounce but you want to be using
the energy from your hips twisting and
punching okay so drive the power from
your hips to kick twist okay to get
twisting and punching very good keep
going to it and punch
look straight ahead one target okay good
and always remember to keep your elbows
and your arms up do not drop them this
is wrong
keep it up and punch strong very nice
good keep twisting and rest it ah
Oh take a deep breath
and breathe out low squat walk right so
again we want to get back into squat ok
squat is a really good beginner workout
which will really work on your lower
body so get into a low squat hold this
position your goal is to move forward
and back by maintaining a low position
good that's it so move forward and back
and that's it ok so inch forward and
inch back the lower you go the more you
will feel your legs and your body
working again beginners if this is too
tough come higher and just take a step
forward and back as you progress go
lower and go deeper dig deep and feel
your glutes working your legs your quads
working all to get the feel that burn
good keep going few more and just shake
it
whoo still working on our legs what I
want to do is take a step forward stand
right in front of your mat we want to do
reverse lunge with a gentle tap on the
floor ok so start with your left leg
back take a step back and tap down
forward and tap down I want you to keep
your both knees bent at a 90 degree
angle good step back and just have to
always maintain a low position right
beginners if this is too tough what you
can do is just take a white step and
just tap on your knees ok good you can
always start here as you progress tap
low that's it I believe that everybody
needs a starting point
whatever your starting point is start
there and slowly progress nice keep
going
tap tap and just shake it out let's go
back and work on our upper body alright
let's work on inchworm to a shoulder tap
so now step right at the edge of your
mat and what a way to do is keep your
leg straight as much as you can slowly
reach down inch forward into a plank and
just tap left and right and slowly go
back okay try to keep your legs straight
throughout again inch forward as you tap
keep your core tight and do not sway
side to side and now step back and up
open up your chest let's go for a few
more forward left right keeping your
core tight and slowly inch back up let's
keep going you are strong ok whatever
your starting point is what is most
important that you are starting this
year very good just shake it out
rest it out now let's get onto the mat
let's start with knee push-ups I know
most of us do not like push-ups because
it's not easy but it's an extremely good
upper-body workout beginners start on
your knees start easy right so on your
knees let's go hence what go as low as
you can and push yourself back up okay
know what are your chance to the mat and
push yourself back up this is wrong okay
do not hike your butt up or do not dip
your hips this is wrong so keeping a
straight line lower your chest and push
yourself up lower using the chest and
shoulder muscles push yourself back up
very good keep going down up down again
and just gently gaze on the floor up
breathe in and out last one
whoa check it out if you want to you can
roll your shoulders and roll your chest
oh okay
stretch your chest out a little bit next
groin us right this is a low-impact
going dryness so start on a high plank
what I wanted to do is bring your left
leg towards your left arm and switch
step back and right to your right palm
okay so step back switch and that's it
and step back into a plank bring your
chest and open up your chest and look up
good so you should feel your hips
working your butt and your hip flexor
being stretched out as well and step
back very good keep going for those of
you if you're not used to this position
you will really feel lots of tightness
around your inner thigh area okay so
keep going step back open up
step back open step back and just relax
two more workouts and you would get a
one-minute break low-impact burpees okay
so again let's start in a high plank
position with low impact burpees what
you can do is you can either choose to
step forward and slowly stand up reach
down and step back if you want to
challenge yourself you can hop in and
step up okay choose your option right
let's go so step back
hop in step up and back down step back
or step in and up good and step back as
you progress hop in and up and hop out
hop in and stand back up very good let's
keep going oh and eventually I know that
you will be able to do a full Burpee
step in and reach up stretch up
rest it out one more final workout okay
I skate with ice skater what I want you
to do is start with both toes pointed
forward cross one leg behind and just
tap down and then change side okay so
let's go one at a time that's your cross
have done and reach down go as low as
you can and feel your glutes working
okay
bend your knees keep your knees bent and
you should feel the squeeze on your
glutes
cross and cross good reach and reach
very nice this is your final workout and
you will get a one-minute break keep
going if you can look straight ahead or
just gently gaze on the floor very nice
keep going keep tapping tap and tap few
more last one and rest it out that was
your first set okay drink some water
keep yourself hydrated you have one
minute break and we want to repeat the
entire workout twice more remember if
this is your first workout or if you
have just started working out take it at
your own pace listen to your body stop
with me - and get back into the workout
when you're ready all right so what is
well can keep yourself hydrated
[Music]
oh just keep breathing what you can do
is that you can always challenge
yourself as well instead of doing a 40
seconds workout with 20 seconds rest you
can always increase the workout time to
45 seconds or even more okay so we have
less than 15 seconds left the first
workout is going to be a highly pool so
always stand in the neutral position
toes pointed forward and feet
shoulder-width apart okay reach up and
bring it down good
so crunch your abs work on your abs good
okay and as you stretch up you should
also be working on your back muscles
good reach down and drive your knees to
your chest very good up and up nice feel
that heart rate feel your muscles
burning feel your sweat dripping that is
your fat crying and burning good keep
going keep driving it down drive it down
nice whoa if you want to tiptoe tiptoe
and few more you can even get into a hub
huh rest it out the little bit okay the
next workout is going to be squat with
front kicks all right I want you to kick
like you made it and remember to always
kick with your heels and keep your knees
soft ready or not here we go let's go
squat down up kick arms up all the time
left alternating between your kicks good
be in control okay
do not just like your leg go loose be in
control nice and pace your breathing
your higher you will feel more on your
legs
all right beginners you can always start
with a low kick and slowly progress kick
up point squat deep
and keep going few more you're almost
there
last one and just shake it out
very good upper body jab cross
we've worked on our lower body now let's
get back on top upper body so again
remember it's all about the movement
from your hips it's not just about your
arms moving okay so in a fighting stunt
wrist and let's go left right twist your
hips and look the opposite side and
really twist and punch directly in front
of you very good
keep going punch it like you're minute
and just relax your shoulders okay do
not tense up your shoulders too much
keep it relaxed and twist your hips work
your hips pivot on your toes
very good punch it it should be at the
same level with your eye line okay so do
not go too low or do not go too high
eyeline look at the target and keep
working
whew and tighten those core and twist
very very nice
let's get back into a lower body workout
low squat walk this workout we really
burn your legs okay second time I want
you to challenge yourself and go lower
so that's that squat stance sugar with a
putt slightly wider let's go walk
forward and walk back
maintain a low position do not come up
hand walk good
halfway through let's swap with a left
leg forward first okay good feel that
burn I want you to feel that burn and do
not come up right now feel that burn
hold it there feelings breathe into the
burn and feel it very good this is a new
year
this is a new you you're starting now
and I want you to see results
holy come on you only have five seconds
left
stay with me okay stay with me oh and
now you can shake it oh oh well done
right now
step right in front of your mat let's do
reverse lunge with a gentle tap okay
choose your option you can either start
by tapping on your knees or tap on the
floor and let's go lunch back tap and
tap again gently gaze down on the floor
tap and tap good keep your body low bend
your knees keep them both 90 degrees and
tap still working on the legs still
driving your heart rate to burn calories
and also fat keep going
alternating between each side and top
good you're almost there in a breathe
out
very nice do you more and rest it out
back to our upper body okay so now stop
right at the edge of the mat let's go to
inchworm
with a shoulder tap so again always
remember shoulder width apart toes
pointed forward keep a leg straight and
now let's reach down and slowly inch
forward into a plank and tap left right
keep your core strong and now inch back
okay leg straight as much as possible
inch forward right left and slowly inch
back feel the stretch and hamstrings
stand up open up your chest and go back
down good
left-right go back whoa
now let's go back down few more inch
back view the stretch up and good job
just come down and rest for a little
while your favorite workout three shots
okay right ready or not let's do this
okay
so get low pumps slightly wider than
your chest level and a way to bring your
entire body down as one unit okay bring
your chest lower chest towards the floor
and push yourself back up okay good and
up squeeze the muscles on your chest as
well as your shoulders so you're working
your chest muscles your shoulders and a
little bit on your triceps again
remember this is wrong
tipping your back is also wrong straight
one line good keep going keep driving it
up and down very nice if this is too
difficult beginners you can always start
by doing small knee push-ups and
eventually slowly lower yourself down
and push back up very good all right
wipe your sweat groin is okay I can see
my sweat dripping and you should be
sweaty as well so let's start in a high
plank position again
all right so left feed to left palm all
right good and back and switch side
ready let's go left feet open up and
stretch those inner thighs and keep
going feel your glutes working as well
good never knew you had those muscles
issues so open up your chest look
forward and keep snapping if this is too
tough again you can always just go as
far as you can and step back okay
even if it's just a small step you gotta
start somewhere and you progress from
there
good keep stepping
and you're alternating very good few
more last one I hadn't just rest it out
oh my god
wipe your sweat next low-impact burpees
okay choose your option you can either
choose to hop in or step in so let's
start again in a high plank position all
right I want you to choose your option
either hop or step in and stand back up
okay hop in up let's go back down step
back
hop in step back up and reach back down
okay hop in up and go back down very
good or step in and slowly reach very
nice keep going good every step you take
you are progressing towards your goal
step in and slowly reach up good step
back step in and reach up look up to the
sky okay you are almost at the end of
your second set
reach up now let's get back up oh my
eyes are literally filled with sweat
okay find a workout ice-skater again
stand face forward cross one leg to the
opposite side ready or not let's finish
it strong
so cross tap down cross and tap good
so gaze gently on the floor right in
front of you keep your body low and
cross and tap good feel the burn on your
glutes
feel the burn on your legs and your
outer thighs good keep crossing and tap
again if this is too difficult you can
just take a step side to side okay as
you progress then go lower
less than 10 seconds tap tap
last one and rest it out that was the
end of step number two take a one-minute
breather rest keep yourself hydrated and
for the final set I want you to give me
your best after the right sir
grab some water and wipe your sweat
but I guess you are doing extremely well
take this precious moment to just keep
us up hydrated you have 20 seconds left
and we want to start with our first
workout which is high knee pull okay I'm
sweaty my hair is a mess but I want you
to look sweaty and messy as well
ready let's go reach up and go pull it
down and reach good pull it down drive
your knee up and if you can tiptoe as
you drive your knee up okay tiptoe and
even get into a small hop there you go
get into a small hop reach as high as
you can and good that's it very good
final set guys final set give me your
best effort give me all your energy you
have less than 10 minutes of workout
keep going
drive it up small hops just small hops
okay good
keep going last one and rest it up squat
with kicks alright ha stand sugar width
apart toes pointed forward kick it like
you mean it
alright show me some bad ass move
alright okay let's go let's start squat
and front kick good ready and go
squat front kick squat and kick go high
okay remember where you started and now
I want you to challenge yourself and
kick higher good if you want to swing
the opposite arm down okay the leg that
goes up the arm goes down good that's it
if your right leg goes up your right arm
goes down good swing it and kick whoa
that way you will have more power in
your kicks kick it and kick okay few
more
breathe in breathe out last one one more
on the other side and shake it out a
little bit very well done
back to our kickboxing movie jab cross
okay and remember I want to emphasize
that the movement of the power comes
from your hips so use this and drive it
from here that way you will be working
on your car so let's go twist it
work on your oblique work on those love
handles and twist it feel that you're
twisting and punching okay it's not a
separate movement it's together so
twisting punch twisting punch and twist
and punch get as you twist that's when
you throw your punch strong punches good
keep going
look straight ahead look at one target
guard your face and keep punching oh I
can see you good come on strong punches
do not drop them right now drive it from
your hips twist pivot on the toast
last one and well done you right now
let's step right in front of the mat
let's go into reverse lunges okay so
reverse lunge with a gentle tap start
with the right leg forward and your left
leg back take a deep breath in and let's
go
tap down stay low and stay low every
time you maintain a low position that's
when you will be recruiting more muscle
fibers from your lower body good
tap down and remember to keep both legs
90 degrees do not lean or hunch forward
okay this is from keep your chest open
and your back straight
if you struggle remember start by
tapping on your knees do not compromise
your form just to get the full movement
okay it is very important that you get
the right form before you try to push
yourself
further keep going and rest it on huh
right let's step back let's get into
inch 1/2 a push up again if you're
struggling you can always start by
bending your knees a little bit if not
let's keep a leg straight and engage
your hand strings even more alright
let's go slowly inch forward and give me
a nice show the tap strong core inch
back stand up squeeze your glutes back
down breathe tap tap and slowly inch
back and up okay beginners again like I
said you can always bend your knees
slightly
reach forward tap tap as you reach back
bend your knees again and stand back
hobble a good few more you are almost
there
you are strong okay do not stop right
now
you stop when you're done ha back down
push up upper body work you gotta get
this right eventually your goal is to be
able to do tofu shops okay so knees
together pump some slightly wider than
chest and make sure they're in line with
your shoulders bring your chest down
close to the mat and push up okay look
straight down do not look straight ahead
you do not want to be straining your
neck so look straight down and push
yourself back up nice push up keeping
your elbows soft so do not jerk and do
not lock your elbows this way okay keep
it in nice soft and in control good blow
it down and up tighten your core suck
your belly in and really feel your
entire upper body as well as the core
muscles working together see your
sweated dripping and that is what I
wanted to feel sweaty burning and I
promise you you'll feel damn good
right after this all right Cronus okay
so again in a high plank position all
right
pumps slightly closer than sugar with a
pot or sugar with a part start in a high
plank position
left palm to left feet okay right back
and step forward
open up do not rush I want you to
stretch and feel your inner thighs
working so open up and feel that stretch
good keep going stretch if you want to
what you can do is add a twist neutral
okay so step back and add a slight twist
good
open up twist and stretch along your
upper body as well open it up good step
back
twist look straight up back twist and
look straight up few more Oh muster up
twisting and rest it out low-impact
burpees okay
right so again start in a high plank you
have three more seconds two more
workouts let's go low-impact burpees
step in reach up reach back down step
out or popping reach up okay choose your
option hop up hop in reach up
let's go challenge yourself add a little
bit of hop down up reach up good down up
reach up belt it's coming up and reach
are very good whew
almost there do not stop right now let's
keep hopping nice give me two more okay
hopping reach up give me one more stand
up and adjust yourself because you have
one workout left ice-skater right
look straight ahead toes pointed forward
I want you to cross the opposite leg
behind again if you want to challenge
enough add a little bit of hop this is
the final workout okay so let's go if
you want to you can just tap or hop into
the workout okay challenge yourself find
your balance and hop side to side and
remember to find your balance look at
one point do not look all over the place
okay look at one point that's how you
will be able to find your balance you're
over there keep hopping hop good and
just reach side to side ten more seconds
left breathe last workout this is a
solid 30 minute
low impact cardio workout oh my hair is
so messy
I am so sweaty but I'm feeling so
amazing so my challenge for you is to do
this workout consistently for the next
month and progress from there okay so
let's get our body warm down and take
this time to catch your breath so just
start with both knees on the floor step
your right leg forward I want you to
shift your weight forward and just feel
the stretch along your hip flexor okay
and what a way to do is place your left
hand cross and just twist good and look
at the opposite side
and just take this moment to breathe
listen to your heart rate listen to your
heart and just bring it back down good
and now just slowly stretch straighten
the right leg and slowly touch to the
floor and feel the stretch along the
hamstring okay
only go as low as you can do not force
yourself to go lower just holy when you
feel that mouthed gentle stretch just
holy there breathe into the stretch and
slowly go deeper okay do not force the
stretch that it's not how much you kept
flexible it's about listening to your
body and working together with your body
okay good now release it and now bend
the front leg okay bend it and what I
wanted to do is straighten the back leg
and slowly lower your upper body down if
that's all you can do that's fine just
start at this level if you feel that you
can go lower then place both elbows on
the floor and reach further if this is
too easy
then go all the way down choose your
option King and feel your glutes your
inner thighs and outer thighs then
stretched out
and now just push yourself back up now
flood
let's switch side okay so opposite side
left leg forward and just push and bring
your weight forward to stretch out the
right hip flexor and now right arm
across twist and look as far back as you
can good so you should also feel your
back your lower back your spine being
stretched out slow down your heart rate
and now just straighten the left leg
toes pointed up and just place both
pants on the floor and feel your
hamstrings being stretched out okay good
lower down as low as you can breathe and
now bend the front leg again straighten
the back leg only go as far as you can
okay you should feel this part choose
your option elbows palms lower your
entire body down
[Music]
and I'll slowly come back up and I want
you just come up into a standing
position okay good
and I'll just roll your shoulders back
row your shoulders forward good just
loosen up the joints you have worked
hard this might be your first workout or
your second workout whatever it is it's
important to stretch and just release
the tension now open up your chest push
your chest forward
feel the stretch on your chest toast
I mean thumbs pointed up and the reverse
thumbs pointing down and push back good
and I'll just shake it out three deep
breaths okay so breathe in bend your
knees
reach up tiptoe and give me a loud time
reach up last one let's go very very
very well done so my goal for you is to
complete it start with this workout do
it at least three times weekly and you
can progress by doing other workouts on
the feel app okay your goal is to stay
consistent on a daily basis remember
everybody needs a starting point this
might be your starting point but if you
keep it consistent you will only get
stronger if you want more full-length
life workout classes be sure to download
my new fitness app fear on the App Store
or go to fear live.com where I and other
instructors will be sharing with you
live classes every single day and you
can do it from the comfort of your own
home don't forget to also give this
video a thumbs up share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos recipe
and also fitness tips remember to start
this year strong and trust me you will
surprise himself all the best